don't bring anyone love into this if you
want to defend it like painful you know
experiences of others like I feel like
it's a defense can you please show do we
have the video I can pull it up look I'm
gonna show you video we're gonna take
video and you just react to it however
I'm not gonna send him up too much just
okay how you want right how I naturally
will now this is interesting that I'm
laughing at stuff that's involuntary
let's say mental illness is involuntary
whereas this person this is saying that
those who harm themselves it's a
voluntary thing oh right
interesting so you understand let's see
the video
I mean it's just like first of all I
don't know
everybody has a different reaction but
I've found that sled Tom watch it comes
watching it
and it's town by the way don't tell me
[Applause]
[Music]
it's pretty funny that's the driver like
how'd that happen are you so loud no the
drivers like you wrecked my car yeah
obviously doesn't like him doesn't give
a fuck about that I don't know if it's
funny they got hit or is funny the
reaction is funny there we go
the reaction like the white whatever the
common word he uses for holy shit yeah
he's pretty funny yes what did you do
[Applause]
you don't think this is funny
um I mean no because I I sense that he's
in a lot of pain I feel badly for him
right I don't really I don't like the
fact that no one's helping him and stuff
but yeah that's just me but if he if he
reacted the way that you expect people
in pain to react like oh my god help me
yeah if I'd have the idea of empathy for
him but that he's just making this crazy
face and screaming these funny duck
noises it's pretty much explanation
rides so this is the this is the whole
thing the reaction time I was talking
about that it's it's a reaction it's how
he's reacting versus that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
muffin guy is like part of the word is
if it were at all in English it would be
different yeah yeah you fucking kill my
shins yeah like it's funny that's really
interesting analysis though that really
uh now I understand
[Laughter]
[Music]